MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
Welcome and thank you so
much for joining us today.
My name is Mario Aretta.
I work in People
Development and part
of the team that manages
programs like gPause
and Search Inside Yourself.
And it's my great pleasure
to introduce this morning
to all of us-- to all
of you-- Frederick Marx.
Nominated for both an Academy
Award and an Emmy Award,
Frederick Marx is a producer,
a director, writer, and editor
with 40 years in the
film and the TV business.
His last film,
"Journey From Zanskar,"
featuring the Dalai
Lama and Richard Gere,
has seen worldwide distribution.
Most known for
"Hoop Dreams," which
was named the Best
Documentary of All Time
by the International
Documentary Association,
Max has screened his films at
the world's most prestigious
festivals, networks, and venues.
All the recognitions include
Chicago Tribune Artist
of the Year, Guggenheim Fellow,
and recipient of a Robert F.
Kennedy Special
Achievement Award.
Frederick has also practiced
mindfulness meditation
for over 20 years,
and is intimately
familiar with different
branches with this practice.
The title of his talk today is
"Living Your Life's Purpose."
Now without further
ado, please welcome
to Google, Frederick Marx.
Thank you so much.
FREDERICK MARX: Thank you.
Well, it's great to be here.
First, I just want
to thank you, Mario,
for going through the trouble to
set this up and make it happen.
And also Bill Duane, who's
part of the same team,
for inviting me here to
speak to all of you today.
It's a real privilege.
I get to fulfill my life's
purpose by being here
to talk to you.
And I've had the
privilege of coming
to understand my own life
in very simple terms.
My life is about two
things, art and service.
That's it.
So this presentation today
is the latter part of that.
It's about service,
it's about me
coming to share
some of what I think
is important, about what I've
learned about life, with all
of you.
And more on that point
in just a few minutes.
So what I want to do now
is just share with you
this film that we just
finished last March,
and this is going to be a lot
of what we talk about today.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-15-year-old.
-14-year-old.
-A 14-year-old and
an 18-year-old--
-Relish the destruction.
-Teen and preteen drug
and alcohol abuse--
-Teenage bullying
is an epidemic.
-A small group of young punks--
-Inducing abortions.
-Theories of murders
and shootings--
-It was mayhem.
-Boys putting their
own lives at risk.
-15-year-old.
-A 15-year-old--
-This teenager--
- --stole a car--
-Gangs of young people--
-Teens in crisis--
-Punks.
A scene like a war zone.
-When a culture doesn't
provide formal rites of passage
or initiations, then you get
usually destructive versions
of it.
-Maybe if we had
other ways for kids
to illustrate their
adult-like qualities,
then they wouldn't resort
to these anti-social ones.
-That's what gang activity is
about, that's what vandalism
and all of that kind of
destruction is about.
It's about how do I prove
to the world that I'm here
and that I'm a man, that I'm
not a little kid anymore?
-Young people, at
a certain age, it's
very natural and
important that they
begin to challenge the
values of their upbringing
and of their culture, and
to begin to go inward.
-How, as communities, do
we respond to this need?
Our social infrastructure
has broken down.
Half of our
marriages fall apart.
Everybody's working so hard,
the community is in fragments.
How do we come together to
provide this for young people?
-Without a mentor as a
companion, it won't work.
Initiation depends on the
generosity of the grown-ups,
and the mentor has
to be someone that's
not going to abandon that boy.
-When communities saw that this
was happening in young people
and they were beginning to rebel
against the cultural values
or the parent values, they
knew, OK, this is good.
Something right is happening.
They're ready and it's time
for them to be initiated.
And so for the health
of the community
and the health of
the individual,
they created rites of
passage ceremonies.
-The question, then,
is do we actually
consecrate those markers?
Do we celebrate those markers?
Do we prepare our
young people so
that-- as they're moving
from one stage to the next--
that they understand
that for every privilege
there is a corresponding
responsibility?
In absence of that,
the day a child
gets a driver's license is the
day they still their mom's car.
The day they are old
enough to buy alcohol
is the day they get drunk.
And one and on and on.
-We are not addressing
the needs of young people,
and we have taken away, I
think, from many of them
opportunities to participate
meaningfully in the community.
It deprives them of this chance
to understand themselves better
and to develop a sense
of being important.
-I don't see it as a
failure of the young,
I see it as a failure
of the elders.
So we, as elders, we
have responsibility.
We have the choice
to speak, to teach,
to show, and hope and bring
the young along with us.
-The human psyche so desperately
needs ceremonial markings.
It is like magic.
-I will find that the
community will be safer,
we'll find that kids will be
less violent, less confused,
less suicidal.
These are better
than meds, better
than going to the prisons
and juvenile facilities.
-Every family unit,
every community,
every big [INAUDIBLE], every
village, city, town, state,
whatever, need to figure out--
for their young people-- what
works.
How do you initiate?
-You start to think about
what your mission is,
what you want to do.
-Initiation and
mentorship has helped me
by realizing that
it's OK to cry.
Not just in front
of men, but in front
of women without feeling like
you're any less of a man.
-After my initiation
with women, every time
I feel myself-- like my
foundation wavering-- instead
of needing to run to my husband
or to these usual go-to people
that are holding so
much, it's my sisters.
It's the women that
can really hold me.
-We also have to ask,
what's the community losing
by not engaging young people?
-If the creator put this
person on the planet,
we're supposed to
nurture them to the point
that we become recipients
of the gift that they have.
That's what rites
of passage told me.
Assist that person's
growth so that when
their gift is revealed to the
world, the world will benefit.
That's an adult's
responsibility.
[END PLAYBACK]
FREDERICK MARX: Well,
thank you for that.
Any questions?
Well, that is an
overview of everything
that I want to
talk about with you
today, so we're going
to just circle back
and zero in on a number
of different subjects
that I raised in the
short film there.
And I want to start by
getting a sense of you folks.
So I want to ask
you some questions
and I just ask you to just
raise your hand if you've ever
asked yourself any of these
questions or, in fact,
might still be
wrestling with them.
What is the purpose of my life?
What am I here on
this planet to do?
Yeah, my hand has been up
for all these questions.
In fact, it still is
up for some of them
and I'm going to be
60 in a few weeks.
So where do I fit in?
What's my place in the
world, in the cosmos?
What, if anything, is
uniquely mine to offer?
What are my gifts?
The Native Americans
used the term medicine.
Their belief is that every
human being represents
a unique medicine that they
are here in this lifetime
to offer their
community, their family,
all of those around them.
So what is your medicine?
And how will I face my
life's coming challenges?
How will I get to
be that man or woman
that I've always wanted to be?
When will I be
accepted and honored
as an equal among elders, among
other adults in this society?
And who or what is
going to help me
across that threshold
of adolescence or young
adulthood into older
adulthood or more maturity?
And in fact, am I
still on that journey?
So even though you all didn't
raise your hands for those,
my guess is that those
questions hit reasonably deep.
So the question that
I ask myself now
is where can young people get
answers to these questions?
Who is out there to
support them in uncovering
answers to these
questions for themselves?
And then, the biggest
question I've asked myself
is, are rites of passage and
mentorship the missing link
in youth development?
In a sense, what I would
call the unifying field
theory of youth development,
almost a silver bullet perhaps.
So this is the bucket of
challenges that's facing us.
You saw some of
that in the film.
No one is really
connecting the dots
and considering that
initiation and mentorship--
which by the way, I think of
as two halves of one whole.
Membership is required
before, during,
and after any kind of initiation
or rite of passage process.
That's just one set of problems,
there's also another problem.
If we don't initiate girls
and boys when they're young,
they grow up and they
live out their lives
in suspended adolescence.
And yeah, Charlie Sheen is the
perfect poster boy for that,
but in fact, take a look around.
We have adults, quote
unquote, "living out
their suspended adolescence"
in all kinds of institutions
across this country.
Government I tend to think of
as Animal House half the time.
You know?
It's a fraternity gone crazy.
Corporations,
other institutions.
So we're all paying
a price for that,
for the uninitiated serving
in these capacities.
It's interesting, too,
I was looking online
and I was curious
how old Google was.
And as you may or may
not know, Google just
passed its 17th anniversary
this month, September 4.
That makes Google a 17-year-old.
So I'm asking
myself, well, what is
Google as an institution
doing to cross
this threshold of adolescence
into young adulthood?
And frankly, I take it
as a very positive sign,
the mindfulness program
that Tan-- that's
his last name, right, Tan?
Meng, I'm sorry,
Meng-- started here
and that Bill Duane
and Mario and others
are implementing across
Googleland, around the world.
To me, that's emblematic
of stepping into maturity
consciously and I really am
curious to see what other steps
Google might be taking
in the near future
to do this consciously.
So long about now you're
probably asking yourself, well,
was I initiated into adulthood?
And if so, what comprised
that experience for me?
So for me, that journey began
when I was nine years old.
My dad died suddenly
of a heart attack,
and I say goodbye to him,
goodnight to him, one day
and he had a heart
attack in the night
and I never saw him again.
So not only did I
not have any closure
with him, but on the
way to the funeral
my uncle-- his younger brother--
he put his hand on my shoulder
and he said, well Freddie,
you're the man of the house
now.
And I was nine.
So the problem in that--
there's a lot of problems--
but one of them is how exactly
am I supposed to do that?
And I wanted desperately
as a nine-year-old
to take care of my mother,
to take care of my older
sister and my younger
brother, but I
had no way of knowing
how to do that
and how to grow into
that responsible man
that I wanted to
be in my lifetime.
And of course saying it
doesn't make it real, right?
I needed initiation,
I needed education
about becoming the man
that I wanted to become.
So in my teen years, I got
way into drugs and alcohol
and fortunately survived
it without hurting myself
or anybody else.
Which is a typical
experience for a lot
of teens unconsciously--
in my view--
seeking that experience
of initiation,
wanting to push
themselves to the edge,
but not having societal
mechanisms to hold
them and keep them safe.
So I never got that
mentorship, my uncle
didn't stick around to
show me how to become
that man that I wanted to be.
I never got it from
many other men,
they weren't there in my life.
Fortunately, I did have--
starting in my late '20s--
a mindfulness practice.
And it started with Buddhism, as
I practiced Buddhism and I did
a chanting practice,
and then it eventually
lead to long meditation
retreats, a daily meditation
practice, and now it's really
one of the fundamental pillars
that holds up my life along
with so-called men's work
and this rites of passage work.
The two of them
together are really
what sustain me in my lifetime.
So you might be thinking
for yourself, well,
what is it that sustains me?
And what was, or did I
have a rite of passage?
So for me, I finally
had it as I was
approaching my 40th birthday.
It was almost exactly
20 years ago in Chicago
that I took a weekend workshop
with a group called The ManKind
Project, a workshop called The
New Warrior Training Adventure.
48 hours, you come at
5:00 PM on a Friday
and leave at 5:00
PM on a Sunday.
And I finally had
that experience
that I so unconsciously
craved as a teen.
And it taught me a number of
really fundamental things.
It taught me about
accountability and integrity.
As a young boy, I
intuitively knew
I wanted to be a man
who could walk his talk,
that when I said something
it was going to happen,
and people could
rest assured in that.
But I didn't know how
to make that happen,
and I also didn't know
what to do in the case
where I had to renegotiate
some agreement.
So that's something that
I learned on that weekend,
was about how to walk my talk,
how to be a man of integrity,
and how to exercise
accountability
in my ongoing daily life.
Another thing it taught
me was about emotions,
about how not to
fear my emotions
or hide my emotions,
but actually how
to learn to recognize
them and to integrate
them effectively
and meaningfully
in my ongoing life.
And for most of us-- as men
especially in this culture--
obviously that is
something we are not
taught by the dominant
culture, right?
If we're given any outlet
at all for our emotions,
it's usually anger
and that's about it.
So that was a
revelation for me--
huge-- that I could actually
access some of these things
like fear, like grief,
like anger, and use them
as energizing tools to
live the life that I
wanted to live as a man.
The other thing
it taught me about
was what we call shadows, which
is a neo-Jungian term-- Carl
Jung, the Swiss philosopher
and psychologist.
Shadows are the dark
side that's in all of us.
Every human being has a
dark side, all of that
that we hide, repress, and deny,
that we do not want to admit
is true for the
beings that we are.
So it took 50 strong men
on this weekend workshop
to basically hold up a mirror
to me and say, take a look.
This is you, too, and you need
to own these parts of yourself.
And if you don't, you're
going to be dangerous.
Because what happens is if
we don't acknowledge and own
the shadows that are in each of
us, they'll leak out sideways.
And before you know
it, we'll be beating up
on children or domestic partners
or abusing ourselves, again,
through drug and alcohol abuse.
Whatever it looks like,
whatever form it takes,
that shadow-driven
behavior comes
from some fundamental
misunderstanding
of who we are as human
beings-- a lie, if you will,
that we took on
when we were young.
I'm not good enough,
I'm not worthy,
I don't deserve success,
I don't deserve happiness.
We all-- in a sense--
carry some of these lies.
So the other thing-- a
number of other things
that it taught me--
but one of them
was how to live in a community
of men cooperatively rather
than competitively.
I had no idea that was possible.
Being a child of this
dominant culture,
I thought, well, men
are supposed to compete.
They're supposed to compete for
scarce resources, jobs, money,
women, whatever.
To experience men
in that environment
where I could actually see
and touch-- if you will--
their open, vulnerable
hearts and have them do
the same with mine, was huge.
It also taught me a little bit
about my mission or my life
purpose.
And everybody has
one, in my belief,
they just need to be
supported in finding it.
And that's something way
bigger than your job or even
your career, it's fundamentally
what you're here on the planet
to do, to accomplish
with your lifetime.
And lastly, it taught me
how the meaning of life
is to be found in service
and not in consumption.
And that's, of course, the
dominant message, right?
Despite what the
bumper sticker says--
whoever dies with
the most toys wins--
we're actually here to serve
and support each other.
And the big
undelivered information
from the dominant culture
is that's actually
where happiness lies.
That we'll actually be
happier as human beings
if we can see the impact of
our actions on those around us
and how it's making
their lives better.
So that's where I first
learned that lesson.
So those are just some of the
lessons that rites of passage
teaches.
Now you just saw this
definition in the movie,
so I'm not going to spend
a lot of time on it,
but I just want to go back over
a couple of key parts of it.
So you know the
old maxim is true,
that it takes a whole
village to raise a child.
Parents can't do it alone.
And doing so-- reaching out
as a parent to a neighbor
or to a coach or to a teacher
or a friend of the family--
actually helps rebuild this torn
and broken fabric of community
that we all suffer from
in this modern world.
Broken and torn communities.
So that's one key thing.
The other is perceived to
be transformative by youth.
It's not for us as adults
to say, OK, you've arrived,
you're a young adult now, you're
a man now, you're a woman now.
We need to have
them evidence this,
and they don't do it through
language by and large,
although that's part of it.
They say wow, I
can't believe what
I've just experienced but man,
I am a different human being.
That's great, but we need
to see it in their eyes.
Alive.
We need to see it in
their body movements.
There's some excitement,
there's some aliveness there,
and some groundedness
there, too.
So the other thing is
offer increased status.
They need to know
that they've arrived,
they're equals now
with us as adults.
And voting, drinking, driving,
having sex, they're not enough.
We need to ritually consecrate
these moments in time,
and ideally come
together as community
to celebrate and acknowledge the
learnings, the education that
has preceded it, that has
justified this moment where
we can celebrate these young
people for this passage.
It's fundamental.
So there's three main stages,
really, of rites of passage.
And this all comes
from Arnold van Gennep,
who wrote about this
over 100 years ago.
Separation or descent
is really one.
We have to separate young
people from everything
that is familiar to
them and yes, that
includes computers and
cell phones and TVs
and all the rest of it.
We have to separate
them from the patterns
that establish their
daily life-- sleep,
food, maybe even dress.
And it's also called descent
because it's dropping.
It's dropping into what
we are fundamentally
as human beings, that
all of that other stuff--
the trappings of daily
modern life-- obfuscate,
cloud, make difficult to see.
So then the key part--
the ordeal or threshold--
it's also called
liminality, that word
that means sort of Twilight
Zone between the worlds.
So there has to be
some kind of ordeal
where the young person is
challenged-- physically,
mentally, spiritually,
emotionally.
They're brought down into
the depths of their being
and they can experience--
at a fundamental level--
just how actually resilient
they are, how strong they are.
They won't know this
until they're tested.
And then the reintegration or
homecoming, as it's called.
So you have to come back
from this experience,
you have to be-- again--
ritually welcomed,
celebrated by your
community and family,
and you have to be
reintegrated so that what's key
here is the learning, the
learning about who you
are as a unique individual,
the gifts that you have.
The elders, ideally,
will help you
understand what
those gifts are so
that you can integrate
them into the community
and start to give them freely.
Because a gift ungiven is a
gift that almost doesn't exist.
It has to be given
to those around.
So what does this look
like for an average teen?
Well, adolescents have to
confront two base fears.
One is leaving
mom and dad, home.
No one wants to do
that, why should you?
You get three meals
a day, ideally, you
have a roof over your
head, you're taken care of.
You have to be-- in
a sense-- forced away
from that relationship.
Some writers on
this subject matter
call it cutting that
second umbilical cord.
That second umbilical
cord, the one
that happens at the
end of adolescence.
That has to be cut and it's
not happening now in society.
We'll return to that subject.
So the other thing, there
has to be-- at some level--
a facing of death.
And the simple truth is it's
bad enough, challenging enough--
and some of you, I'm sure,
have experienced this
like I have one-- when somebody
close to you in your family,
somebody dear to you has died.
That, in a sense, can be a
beginning of a rite of passage.
If you have the proper
mentorship from an elder,
they can help you
understand what
is the meaning of this moment
in time in your lifetime?
I didn't have that when I was
nine years old, from my uncle
or anybody else.
But even more than that,
we have to understand
our own mortality,
the fragility and yet
the preciousness of
this very sacred thing
of our own human life.
And until we're brought
into proximity with death,
until we at least fear
that we're going to die,
we're not going to
experience that.
It's not going to happen.
We'll unconsciously fear
it the rest of our lives,
but we won't know in
our hearts and souls
what our capacity is
to withstand challenges
and to face death.
So the ordeal-- in a sense,
what's called for here
is the young person
needs to metaphorically
die to their childhood self
to be reborn as an adult.
And then the reintegration--
one of the key lessons that's
a part of rite of passage
that needs to be brought back
into community is every
child and every adolescent
tends to see the world in
a me, me, me kind of way.
And to be a
fully-mature adult, it
requires us to see
things as us, us, us.
We need to do it
together, because
without that cooperation,
there is only domination.
So there's lots of different
forms of rites of passage
that still exist
around the world,
these are just some of them.
And it's interesting
because all of the damage
that we've done to
indigenous cultures
around the world who have
understood for thousands
of years-- the African
proverb that you saw
at the beginning of the film.
"If we do not
initiate the young,
they will burn down the
village to feel the heat."
It's a beautiful proverb.
Indigenous cultures-- in their
own way across the globe--
have understood this,
have understood this.
So it's interesting because some
of what has survived in time
are some of these ceremonies,
some of these processes.
But I'm curious, are any of
you Jewish out there like I am?
OK, I don't know
about you, but when
it was my friends'
time for bar mitzvah
there was one
question that came up.
What did you get?
It was not, how are
you transformed?
Are you a different being?
Do you feel like a man now?
And that's just
an example of how
so many of these processes that
still have survived to this day
have been co-opted
by consumer culture,
and they've lost that
essential potency
that's required to drive
transformation and make
it happen.
There's a couple of other
key fundamental lessons--
in my experience-- that result
as a process of healthy rite
of passage or initiation.
Knowing your place in the
cosmos is one of them.
There's a fundamental
paradox that's
I think at the essence of
every human life, and that is--
and I was reminded of that
a couple days ago when
I was watching the beautiful
blood moon in the eclipse,
I don't know if any
of you saw that-- how
small and insignificant
we are at one level,
in the greater
scheme of the cosmos.
We are specks of dust.
But the other half of
that paradoxical equation
is that each of us is
immeasurably powerful.
Immeasurably, and that there's
literally no limit to what
we can manifest and how
we can impact and change
the lives of those around us.
So holding that paradox-- and
in fact experiencing it almost
in the bodily way--
is a fundamental part
of a healthy rite of passage.
So knowing that you're
part of the web of life
is also a part of that.
That you don't exist apart from
trees and rocks and waters.
We don't exist.
Knowing your mission
or life purpose.
I already spoke to that.
Another way of saying that,
again, is gifts or medicine.
Beautiful terms.
Knowing the depths of your
physical and mental capacities.
Again, I think that's part of
why young people put themselves
through trials.
Well, let's see if we
can drink, let's see
if we can drink three
cases in about 10 minutes.
Unconsciously, I think that
part of the drive toward that
is seeing, what is the
limit of this physical body?
Emotions and how to handle them.
I just myself did
another rite of passage--
if you will-- a
Vision Quest, and I
spent four days up
in the Eastern Sierra
at about 10,000 feet in a
mountain desert fasting.
It was about 100 degrees
every day, and believe me,
all kinds of emotions came up.
So it gave me an
opportunity again
to look at fear, to look a grief
that surfaced as I recollected
and thought back on mistakes
that I've made in my lifetime,
to look at all of my
emotions and to reintegrate
them and understand
them and not fear them.
Again, service to community.
That's an essential component,
as well as self-empowerment.
So imagine-- if you will--
that we live in a society
where all teens have a deep
sense of purpose for their life
and they're connected to
their deepest passions.
Imagine that we live in a
world where all teens know
their physical, mental,
spiritual, and emotional limit,
so they don't have to seek them
through unconscious trials.
And imagine all teens know the
rights and responsibilities
of adulthood, and feel
welcome and accepted
by elders, by older adults.
And imagine that they're
actually stakeholders
in their community,
deeply invested
in a community that's thriving.
I think that's part of the
reason I live in Oakland,
and I think that's part of
the reason why we have so
many disaffected young people.
Nobody's coming up to
them saying, I see you,
I see the brilliance that you
carry, I see some of the gifts
that you have.
Please offer them, bring
them into our community,
you are a stakeholder here.
And give them the room
to start to manifest
some of that brilliance.
We don't do it.
So imagine, too,
that all parents
know when it's their time to
let their young people go forth
on their own.
This is a problem,
like I said before.
And yes, I get it, it's
partly an economic issue.
It's really, really
tough now for most people
in their '20s to get good jobs,
to find decent-paying work.
And it's especially tough--
interestingly enough--
for boys, for young men,
at an almost two to one
ratio to women.
But in addition to that, there's
no dominant cultural support
for parents to say, you have
got to turn your young person
loose.
Otherwise, they won't
manifest their own greatness,
they won't reach their
potential as human beings.
I gave a talk about a year
ago in North Carolina,
and there was a woman who
came up to me afterward.
She said, I'm so glad to
hear your talk because I
kick my kids of the
house at 18 and I just
felt like they really needed it.
And my point is not to condone
or condemn-- I don't know her
and I don't know her
kids or her situation,
whether it was the right
choice of the wrong choice--
but what I do know is there's
no cultural support for her.
There's no community
support for her
in making that choice,
in affirming that choice
or saying no, maybe
it's too early,
maybe they need
another couple years.
And lastly, imagine no
more suspended adolescents
running the country.
How sweet would that be?
It's interesting
because it makes
me reflect on John Boehner
and his stepping down
from Animal House.
I actually think that was
a very moral, and in fact,
and noble decision
on his part to make.
And I saw it as a
real culmination
in a way of his own
rite of passage,
in trying to run herd over
this thing called Congress
over the last few
years where so many
of the members of his own party
are giving him the greatest
grief.
He's like, no, enough, I'm
going to step away from this.
We could go into that, but I
don't have time for it now.
So ultimately, young
people have to find a way
to live their dreams,
heal their spirits,
and to change the world.
We need to give them
those opportunities.
This I won't go into, this
is some of what we're doing.
As I said, I'm about
art and service,
I am not the ideal selected
guy to head a social movement.
And yet that's
what I found myself
doing because I didn't
see anybody else doing it.
And I thought, this is
essential, we have to do this.
So these are some of
the things that we've
been doing over
the last few years
to really try to reawaken
the adults of this world
to their responsibilities
to young people.
So let me share one
last film with you
and then I'll close here.
So this is the voices of
the young people speaking
for themselves about what
it is that they need.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-There's so much struggle that
our kids are going through.
-Kids don't have
the attention, even
from their parents, because
they're so busy working.
-What's our world going to be
in the future, our generation?
What are we going
to do, how are we
going to step up to the plate?
-We have the opportunity to
help other human beings out,
and I kind of feel it's
our responsibility to.
-So I'll need to be
more giving and I'll
need to be disciplined to
know what should be going on.
-Sometimes I feel
like I need there
to be an adult for me to be
able to talk about it, you know?
About sex and drugs
and-- I fear it
because I don't know about it.
-Don't be afraid to take risks.
-It all starts with
one person, really.
One person can change the world.
-If you respect me--
-I will hear you.
-If you listen to me--
-I will feel understood.
-If you understand me--
-I will feel appreciated.
-If you appreciate me--
-I will know your support.
-If you support me--
-As I try new things--
-I will become responsible.
-When I am responsible--
-I will grow to be independent.
-In my independence--
-I will respect you and
love you all of my life.
[END PLAYBACK]
FREDERICK MARX: To get us there,
all that's needed, really,
are community-based,
culturally-tailored rites
of passage and mentorship.
And the promise that's before us
is that if we do that, then all
our young people-- in
their independence--
are going to love us and honor
us for the rest of their lives.
So thank you, appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: You talked about--
in the film-- regionally,
culturally specific
rites of passage.
I was involved in a summer
mathematics program--
and I know maybe
other people here
have been involved in the
first robotics program--
and there was those sorts of
experiences for people who
were mathematically-inclined
or technically-inclined,
but that was a very
specific rite of passage.
It wouldn't work for
lots and lots of people,
but it really worked
for those people.
But what about those
individually specific rites
of passage?
FREDERICK MARX: Well,
that's absolutely-- I'm not
sure what you're asking.
It's wonderful and
it's appropriate
and that was right for
you and that's great.
But it sounds like
you weren't alone,
though, you had a
cohort with you.
All the better.
Ideally it's never
an isolated act.
We might be isolated
for parts of the ordeal,
but we always have
to begin and end
in integration with community.
The more that you can experience
an ordeal in conjunction
and relationship with
others, the deeper you'll
understand your
interconnectedness
and the deeper those bonds
of love will be driven.
So fantastic, great.
AUDIENCE: My question is
basically around balancing
between the importance of the
individual and the community.
I myself was raised Catholic
and I went through confirmation,
and it wasn't a very valuable
experience in my mind.
So what I'm wondering
is how do you
ensure that these rites of
passage-- in some ways--
don't become codified
to meaninglessness
when everyone
around you is going
through the same
rite of passage?
Such that it doesn't
mean anything
to you because everyone else
is doing the same thing.
FREDERICK MARX: Well
again, that gets back
to the definition of the
efficacy of a rite of passage.
We need to hear the testimony
from the young people
themselves.
They have to be the ones to say
I'm the proof of the pudding,
this worked.
And if it didn't, then we need
to offer them something else.
But that's the function
of elders in society,
too, because they're constantly
alert to the responses
that the young people are
giving and they can see,
well, Joey's not really
responding to this.
What does he need?
What do we need to
do with and for him
that's going to give
him a deeper experience?
So that's essential.
And it's interesting, too-- I'll
use your question to spring off
a little bit-- it's both and.
Meaning if you're
Catholic, great.
Ideally we have
Catholic confirmation
as rites of passage that
are potent, that actually
do what they're designed to do,
to grow you into that man you
want to become.
But we also have to
make room for Catholics
like yourself who say, I don't
want that for whatever reason.
We have to respect that,
too, and offer them
something else that will
also give them an opportunity
to discover their
gifts, but maybe
outside of that
Catholic context.
AUDIENCE: I know there was a
slide that mentioned the three
phases of the rite of passage.
Is there any sort
of research more
specifically into
various things to do?
I know, for example,
there's a lot of research
with psychedelics, on
exactly how they help
and exactly what doses and how
to make this process something
you could almost
count on for people
who are dealing with cancer
or dying and stuff like that.
But is there a way to
use research and science
to understand what these
tipping points are for people?
I know it's a lot
of behavioral stuff,
which then means lots of
people locked away for however
much time, and then lots
of funding to do that.
But I think everyone would agree
depression's bad, suicide's
bad, binge drinking's
bad, and all that stuff.
But to have the cultural
shift to understand
that it's something that
is logical and actually
really important and
good to invest in just
like college or everything else,
that maybe it's something--
Again, this shift away
from I think our approach
to drugs-- and the same thing,
an approach to rite of passage
is just a long change
to engender culturally.
And just, I guess maybe, the
specifics around research
around that or the process.
I think on one of the slides
you mentioned the YMCA, trying
to collaborate with them, but
just where does the rubber
actually meet the
road, and how to tip
people's perspective into taking
action and getting involved?
FREDERICK MARX:
Well that last piece
was a little bit different,
but the substance
of your question-- I
can say I'm sure there's
scientific evidence that
is in formative stages
around this stuff, but
this work is so new
that a lot of the data is
just now starting to come in.
And it's coming in, in
very rudimentary forms.
There's a group in San
Diego called Boys to Men,
so they have statistics that
verify that attendance goes up,
grade average goes
up, et cetera,
for high school boys who attend
their program, et cetera.
But by and large, we're still
in the very early stages
of the scientific evidence
that you're alluding to.
But the whole issue of
drugs that you raise
is also an interesting
one, because certainly
many indigenous cultures
throughout the planet
use psychotropic plants as part
of the initiation ceremonies.
In fact, Iowaska--
which most of you
are probably familiar
with, it's come now
to North America
from South America--
was used fundamentally for
that purpose for many years.
And there's also
Martin Prechtel,
who wrote many wonderful
books about Central American
initiation, the
native Mayan people.
One of the things that he talked
about was how one of the first
exercises they would
do with the elders--
they'd take the boys
out in the wilderness
and get them drunk as
skunks so that they
could begin to experience that,
but in a safe and contained
way.
So that's the best answer I can
give you, I'm afraid, for now.
Do you have a follow up?
AUDIENCE: I guess just maybe
organizations like the YMCA
or actual behavioral research
in a university setting.
Some way where the Western
mind or the North American
mind-- and I know
every culture's
very different, even within.
There's micro-cultures,
obviously, within our country--
but to understand
in a pragmatic way,
regardless of your religion
or your family structure
or whatever else,
that these are things
that grade attendance goes up.
And maybe it's leapfrogging
off that Boys to Men thing
but as opposed to
one organization,
that it becomes a
cultural thing that people
are aware of as being extremely
helpful-- that can meet
organizations like schools
and/or religious organizations
of all kinds-- and that
it's a human experience.
The reason I ask
about the research
is there's something--
I think when
you push your physical
limits in a fast
or in certain endeavors--
that nothing else matters,
because you are feeling
things in a way-- in the fiber
of your bodyy-- that can't
be ignored regardless
of what you thought
before or anything else.
FREDERICK MARX: Yeah.
Well again, the
scientific evidence
is just in the formative
stages, but that
is part of the task of the
organization that I co-founded
called Youth Passageways, is to
begin to assemble and collate
all of these studies
and all of this data.
But in addition to that--
and I went through the card
so quickly, I'll restate
it-- we at my company--
it's a nonprofit
called Warrior Films--
we have written six world-class
curricula or toolkits.
Parents; high schools;
colleges and universities;
therapists, counselors,
psychologists;
youth development centers;
and faith-based institutions.
So we're basically
offering them ideas
for curricula, how
they can implement
some of these practices
into their own cultures.
So places like
YMCAs, for example.
So please, go online and help
yourselves to these things.
We're giving them away.
And there's a lot of
helpful tools in there,
especially if any
of you are parents.
Most of you are probably
too young to have teens,
but at any rate, if
you know people who are
parents with struggling teens.
And even the high
school curriculum,
we broke it down by job.
So teachers, there's
one set of ideas
for, administrators,
and also counselors.
So this is-- yeah, enough said.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just to follow
up on that question,
you mentioned beautiful
things like creating
teens more connected to
their deepest passion
and feeling accepted,
reaching potential.
And you were saying
that you have
practical tools for parents
so they can actually know
how to support their teens.
Do you have maybe a
few highlights or tips
that you can mention now?
Like what are the things that
you suggest to those parents
to actually help their teens
to go through that process?
FREDERICK MARX:
Yeah, absolutely.
Well in fact, the
parents curriculum,
it starts with them at
about sixth grade-- so 12,
13 years old.
And for every year
for six years,
we have a whole set of different
ideas for things we can do.
So one example that
comes right to my mind--
because I faced this
with my niece recently--
she just turned 16
in January and we
were trying to get
her-- on her own--
to take a trip out to see us.
She lives with my sister
right outside New York City.
And that's one of the things
that is in this program,
it's designing trips
for young people
to experience the
world on their own.
It can start with day
trips, just even walking
around their community
and seeing it, perhaps,
for the first time with
new eyes in different ways.
And building up to
things like that,
where you go
cross-country on your own,
the first time ever on
a plane by yourself,
and get yourself
to someplace else.
And then to also
journal along that way,
so that they can begin to
track their own fears and then
their own surmounting
of those fears.
So I hope that's a good example.
AUDIENCE: I actually came
because I just signed up
to be a mentor for
the first time.
FREDERICK MARX: Yay.
AUDIENCE: So I came more
for a personal perspective.
And I was wondering if you
had any suggestions or advice
for how-- as a mentor
on a limited timeframe--
I can actually help this
transition along given
that I can't create or implement
a specific rite of passage.
FREDERICK MARX: Well,
I'll try to give you
a crash course in what I know of
mentorship in a minute or less.
First of all, you've
got to be accountable
to that young person.
So whatever time you set to
meet them, you've got to do it.
And if you don't, then
you have to renegotiate
and be accountable for it.
Regularity is key, as you
probably already know.
Ideally once a week or
more for a couple hours.
I use the 80-20 ratio, listening
to them 80% of the time
and speaking 20%.
So many of us think,
OK, I'm a mentor now,
I've got to share
all my life wisdom
and I'm going to
tell you what to do.
No, it's about listening to
them and deeply understanding
where they're at,
and going from there.
Just in that listening,
we bless them
through our kind and
compassionate attention.
That is one of the greatest
gifts a mentor can bring.
So that's some of it.
I hope that's helpful.
And bless you for doing that.
In fact, that's my final
question to all of you.
How many of you are
mentoring and how many of you
are being mentored?
Because that's how we reform,
again, the torn fabric
of community and that's how
we create links through time.
That's how generational
links happen.
So as I told you, I'm
turning 60 in a few weeks.
Believe me, I still have
mentors who I can turn to,
to give me all kinds of
advice when I need it
and also to kick my
ass when I need it.
And I sure as heck
am also mentoring
a number of young people.
And sometimes not young--
my age or even older--
but also offering
those that mentorship.
So I really invite you to do
that, because it's essential.
And here's another one for you.
If you're not growing as
much as that young person,
something's wrong.
Something is
fundamentally wrong,
because you need to be growing
yourself in the process.
And if you're not, then you
really need to retool it.
Thank you all again.